thank you and may god bless america
all right couple introductions with your
child here this is john o'rourke nice to
meet you joshua ian roberts
nice to meet you peter tencio all right
nice to meet you
jerome smith come on brother what's up
fam
you know this keith williamson nice to
meet you mary woodbury nice to meet you
jay martel nice to meet you sir
tasha robinson come on come on come on
feel that emily george all right
nice to meet you daryl stokes come on
what's up fam
how you doing all right never forget
about that
cause that's all we got nice to meet you
all right oh bring it down bring it in
starting from the bottom now we're here
yeah nice to meet you
all right nice to meet you all right
nice
1 8 black afternoon in my octo room come
on bring it in there
yeah i'm in the dog i'm in there i'm in
your dog you're talking about that
what's your
you cut name in there i'm in there all
right nice to meet you man
uh nice to meet you oh my goodness look
at this
oh she is so beautiful
um i want another one there you go
precious
beautiful beautiful what's her name oh
this is livia roojie
okay nice to meet you miss rougey all
right
come on larry
boom all right very good to meet you all
right here we go
right this way sir